[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
توتر في الضفه الغربيه مقتل اربعه
مستوطنين شمال رام الله واعتداءات
اسرائيليه على اهالي حواره
على حافه التماس مع مناطق المعارضه
وغدادها مباحثات في استانا الجيش السوري
يدفع بتعزيزات الى ريف حلب
كاميرا العربيه تدخل مدينه المحاصره من
ثلاث جهات بعدما تحولت الى مدينه اشباح
اثر القصف الروسي
عيون العالم ترقب اعماق المحيط الاطلسي
ساعات مثيره بحثا عن غواصه تيتان
لائحه
بين الامريكيين الديمقراطيون والجمهوريون
يتشاركون مخاوفا انعدام الثقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه والبدايه طبعا
من تطورات الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه حيث
اعلن الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تسجيل 36
اصابه جراء اعتداء الجيش الاسرائيلي
ومستوطنين على سكان حواره هذه التطورات
جاءت بعد مقتل اربعه مستوطنين في هجوم
المسلح قرب مستوطنه في شمال رام الله على
يد مسلحين اثنين الجيش الاسرائيلي لاحقا
قتل احد المهاجمين في موقع الحادث وقتل
اخر في مدينه طوباس شمالي نابلس بعد
مطاردته وفق ما نقلت مصادر اسرائيليه
هذا واقدم مستوطنون اسرائيليون على احراق
حقول زراعيه في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس كما
نشاهد في هذه الصور
عقب اجتماع امني لوح رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو باللجوء الى
الخيارات كافه لمحاربه ما وصفه بالارهاب
بكل قوه في حين دعا وزير الامن القومي
اثمار بن جبير الى شن عمليه عسكريه واسعه
النطاق في الضفه وتشريع قانون حكم الاعدام
لمنفذي العمليات من الفلسطينيين هل
التطورات جاءت بعد يوم من تلميحات لوزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بامكانيه اجراء عمليه عسكريه واسعه في
الضفه الغربيه بهدف الحفاظ على حريه
النشاط الامنيه الاسرائيلي خصوصا في مدينه
جنين
لقد اثبتنا بالفعل في الاشهر الماضيه اننا
قمنا بتسويه الحسابات مع جميع القتلات دون
استثناء كل من هاجمنا هو اما في القبر او
في السجن سيكون هذا هو الحال في هذه
الحادثه ايضا لكني اريد ان اخبر كل اولئك
الذين يسعون الى الحاق الضرر بنا سنواصل
محاربه الارهاب بكل قوه وسنفوز
نتابع من رام الله مع عصمت منصور الخبير
في شؤون الاسرائيليه ومن القدس الى نيسان
المحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما استاذ عصمت ما
مدى خطوره الوضع بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين برايك هذه المره
تحياتي لكم واضح ان الوضع خطير والامور
تتجه اكثر واكثر نحو التصعيد اعتماد حكومه
الاحتلال على القوه
في التعامل مع الحلل الفلسطينيه على
الاتحادات كما حدث بالامس في جنين واعدام
الشبان والقصف بالطيران
وتكثيف الاستيطان هذه كلها عوامل تدفع
اكثر نحو التصعيد ونحو خروج عمليات من هذا
النوع
والتصدي
لاحتلال لذلك يعني طالما انه الحل السياسي
غائب طلبات الافق السياسي مغلق كليا وقضى
انه الامور تتجه اكثر واكثر نحو التصعيد
ونحن امام حكومه تجاهر بان سياستها
العلنيه هي الحسم هي الحسم ومن خلال قوه
ومن خلال الاستيطان لذلك امام هكذا وضع لا
يملك الفلسطيني سوى ان يدافع عن وجوده
الذي اصبح مهدد بشكل فعلي سيد ايلي نيسان
هذا الهجوم في مستوطنه عيله جاء بعد 24
ساعه على قت الجيش الاسرائيلي سته
فلسطينيين في جنين شمالي الضفه
الغربيه هل ستكون هناك عمليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه واسعه في الضفه
اريد ان افرق بين ما قام به قام به
المخربان اثنين اليوم عندما قاموا بقتل
اناس ابرياء
الذين كانوا يتناولون مادوبه العشاء او
مادوبه
الغداء في المطعم وبينما قام به قامت به
وحده من جيش الدفاع في جنين
قوات جيش الدفاع التي اقتحمت يوم امس
مخيم جنين قاموا بالقاء القط على
من يخططوا بقتل وتنفيذ عمليات تخريبيه
داخل اسرائيل ولذلك لا يمكن التمييز بينما
قام به هؤلاء المخربان اليوم الذين قتلوا
مدنيين ابرياء وبين ما قامت به وحده جيش
الدفاع بقتل المخربين وط
بعا راينا ما حدث من فقط يعني نعم الان
سيد ايلين نعم لم تجيبني على سؤالي هل
ستكون هناك عمليه عسكريه كبيره هذه المره
اذا تسمح لي ان ارد هذه مثل ما لم تقاتل
السيف من رام الله انا اردنا اريد ان اخذ
قدر الامكان اجابتك على السؤال سيد اليه
ارجوك ارجوك
استمعت للفكره نريد ان نتوسع رجاء ارجوك
ارجوك سيد الي ارجوك ان تحافظ على هدوءك
والا تنفعل علي رجاء نحن نحاول ان نجري
حوارا هادئا سيد ايلي رجاء من فضلك من
فضلك
عروض على السؤال نعم انا سالت السؤال انت
توسعت في نقطه واتممتها للاخير رجاء هل
هناك عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه واسعه في
الضفه هذه المره هذا هو سؤال الذي لم تجب
لي عنه تفضل
سيد
اليوم مشاورات برئاسه رئيس الوزراء
في المرحله الاولى
في منطقه منطقه شمال الضفه الغربيه هذه
نقطه اولى في
النقاشات التي كانت مساء اليوم كان هناك
تباين في مواقف بعض بعض
الاطراف في حين الجهاز الامن العام وبعض
الجهات الامنيه في الجيش الدفاع يطالبون
القيام بعمليه ليس على نمط الذي كان في
كان اسرائيل لا تريد من خلال هذه العمليه
انهيار السلطه الفلسطينيه ولا تريد
اسرائيل المساس بمدنيين وايضا هناك تفكير
اعاده تفكير اذا كان هناك في الامكان وضع
حواجز الامر الذي
يضع المزيد من العراقيين على السكان يعني
تعتقد انه مستويات الرد يعني ستبقى في هذا
عند هذا المستوى سيد عصمت في رام الله طيب
يعني مشهد اجتياحا كبيرا كما في 2002 سيد
عصمت منصور ما رايك فيما قاله السيد
الينسان بان اسرائيل يعني عندما قتلت
الفلسطينيين في جنين مؤخرا يعني بالامس هي
كانت تستهدف مطلوبين امنيين بينما عمليه
عيله اليوم كما قال السيد ايلي نيسان هي
استهدفت ابرياء
يعني هذا كلام فارغ مع الاحترام يعني هذا
هذه قوه احتلال تدخل بمدرعات مصفحه
وبالطيران لمناطق مدنيه حتى لو تحصل فيها
مطلوب او مطلوبين هي تعيد فسادا وتكثر
هناك طفله عمرها يعني سنوات مصابه ويعني
ربما فيها ان تعيش حالك موت سريري ايضا
يعني الذين قتلوا اليوم هم مستوطنين بيوفق
القانون الدولي ليس وفقنا نحن القانون
الدولي هذه ارض محتله ووجودهم هو عباره عن
سرقه لهذه الارض واحتلال لها بالقوه
العسكريه الدفاع عن النفس هذا حق مشروع
لنا كفلسطينيين نفكر كانون الدولي لذلك
يعني هذه المقاربات والروايه الاسرائيليه
ومحاوله اقناع انفسهم والعالم بها هذا
يتنافى مع القانون الدولي يتنافى مع
الواقع الذي يمارس القوه العسكريه
والاحتلال العسكري وارتكب مجازر ويعدم
الشبان هو احتلال الاسرائيلي وكنت
العسكريه
سيد عصمت كذلك بدلافتا في عمليه اليوم
تبني حركه حماس لها ما دلاله هذا التبني
الان في هذه المرحله في هذه المره على
خلاف المرات السابقه
يعني فعلا هذا احد التطورات اللافته في
هذه العمليه انها ليست فرديه ولا ارتجاليه
كما تعودنا في السنوات او الفترات السابقه
كانت تتم العمليات بشكل عفوي اشخاص
بسكاكين بسيارات وربما احيانا باسلحه
مصنعه محليا الان هذه عمليه تبنتها رسميا
حركه حماس هذا يعني ان توجه الحركه هو نحو
نحو التصعيد في الضفه وتكثيف المقاومه
واعتقد انه ربما هذا يدفع ان يكون رد
الاحتلال ليس فقط من خلال عمليه عسكريه
وانا استبعد ذلك جدا لاسباب كثيره وربما
يكون الرد من خلال تهديد غزه او اغتيالات
في الخارج سيد ايلي نيسان كما قال ضيفي من
رام الله وكذلك مواقف فلسطينيه اخرى
اعتبرت انه عمليه اليوم هي رد طبيعي على
الاستهدافات التي تلحق بالفلسطينيين وكذلك
الممارسات العنصريه والرغبه في تسريع
الاستيطان كما نتحدث كذلك رغبه هذه
الحكومه الحاليه في اسرائيل
هل برايك يعني الا ينبئ هذا بان العنف لا
يولد الا العنف
انا اعرض لك عن كل شيء بس انا اطلب منك لا
تقاطعني كما لم تقاطع الضيف من رام الله
طيب
اولا القضيه في جنين وفي نابلس بدات بعقاب
تخادل السلطه الفلسطينيه
والفراغ الكبير الذي احددته السلطه
الفلسطينيه في كل من مدينتي جنين ونابلس
وعندما يكون فراغ هناك طبعا نرى على سبيل
المثال جهاد الاسلامي وحركه حماس
بايحاء ايران الذي تمول هذه العمليات
القتل في في شمال ضفه ضفه الغربيه طبعا لم
يكن مفار امام اسرائيل اسرائيل كما قلت
انا لا تريد انهيار السلطه الفلسطينيه
ولكن عندما
السلطه الفلسطينيه سيد اليه
طبعا اسرائيل لا تريد ان تكون مسؤوله عن
الامور في الضفه الغربيه بشكل خاص في
نابلس وفي جنين ولكن عندما لا تقوم السلطه
الفلسطينيه بواجبها طبعا هناك اولا نرى
الحمى حماس وجهات واذا لم تكون سلطه
الفلسطينيه اسرائيل تضطر ان تتدخل في
مدينتي جنين ونابلس سؤال النقطه الاخرى
كما يقول لضيفك من رام الله هل مقتل
مدنيين
ابرياء يؤدي الى اي حل سياسي والى اي حال
للتغلب على المشاكل بين اسرائيل وسلطه
الفلسطينيه ولذلك انا اقول حركه حماس تلعب
على حبلين الحبل الاول هي تريد
المحافظه على الهدوء في قطاع غزه لان هذا
من مصلحه حركه حماس والثانيه تريد
اشعار فتي في الضفه الغربيه ومن يدفع
الثمن في نهايه الامر ليس حركه حماس وانما
السكان في الضفه الغربيه انت
انت ترى انه اذا استجابت الحكومه في
اسرائيل لوضع حواجز كما يطالبون
المستوطنون في انحاء
جنين ونابلس طبعا هذا الامر يشكل على
التجاره او على الحياه في في
قطاع غزه في ضفه الغربيه وانا اقول لك
نقطه نقطه مهمه لم تكن عمليه على نطاق ما
كان في 2002 ولكن عندما نرى تغيير في
الاوضاع الامنيه في نابلس وفي جنين طبعا
الرد الاسرائيلي سيكون على شبه ما تقوم به
المنظمات الارابيه حماس وجهاد الاسلامي
وترعى عاجلا ام اجلا ان اسرائيل تقوم بهذه
العمليه واسعه النطاق
لقطع في الضفه الغربيه شكرا لك لنيسان
المحلل السياسي من
عفوا
انا اطلب ان تكونوا منصفين في النقاش لا
انا كما تعطيني
كلا هذا لم يحدث لنا يعني حاولت
فرصه لكل الافكار سيد فقط وتنحن وقتنا
يعني محصور بدقائق معدوده ونريد اخذ كل
المواقف والاجابه على العديد من الاسئله
لعلنا يعني نتوقف عند هذا الحد نحن
تجاوزنا الحد الوقت بكثير حتى اعطيك وقتك
وزياده عصمه منصور كذلك الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
طيب لدينا مجموعه من الاخبار العاجله كما
يشار اليه
طيب مجلس حضرموت اذا اعوج المتعلقه باليمن
مجلس حضرموت تعزيز القوات المسلحه بعناصر
من من ابناء حضرموت ومنع انشاء تشكيلات
خارجه الدوله مجلس حضرموت ايضا يعلن
المبادئ اعلان المبادئ اذا الذي ينص على
تبني اليات لحمايه مصالح ابناء
المحافظه مكونات وقوان سياسيه اذا في
حضرموت تؤكد ان مجلس حضرموت الوطني سيلتزم
بوحدتها واداره شؤونها مجلس حضرموت الوطني
ايضا يؤكد على الالتزام بالاهداف المشتركه
مع تحالف دعم الشرعيه اذا هذه هذا يبدو
تطورا مهما فيما يتعلق بالوضع في حضرموت
في اليمن التعهد بالتحديد مؤسسات الدوله
تحييدها عن اي خلافات تضر بالمصالح العامه
الكلام هنا دائما اذا لمجلس حضرموت الوطني
على العموم سنتابع المزيد حول هذا التطور
ما يحدث هناك في حضرموت في اليمن لاحقا
حاله توفر المزيد من المعطيات حول هذا
البيان من مجلس
حضرموت واعلان المبادئ الذي يعلن اذن اليه
جديده لحمايه مصالح هذه المحافظه الى
السودان الان حيث نشر الجيش صورا لما يبدو
انه حريق كبير مما قر المخابرات في
الخرطوم حيث افادت مصادر عسكريه سودانيه
بان الدعم السريع قصف المقر الرئيسي لجهاز
المخابرات العامه في الخرطوم بدورها قالت
مصادر بقوات الدعم السريع ان الجيش قصف
بالمسيرات مواقع تمركزها قرب جهاز
المخابرات واحرق المبدا ويقر او يقع المقر
مقر المخابرات في نفس المجمع الذي يضم
وزاره الدفاع والقياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه ومقر
الاقامه الرئاسي
وايضا شبح الحرب الاهليه يحوم مجددا حول
السودان مؤشرات عديده بدات تنظر بامكانيه
وقوع الصراع في منزلق الحرب الاهليه اولى
هذه المؤشرات تصريح وحاكم اقليم دارفور من
اركو منوي الذي قال ان ما يحدث في الجنينه
وكتم جرائم مكتمله مضيفا ان الاغتيالات
التي تجري قد تقود المجتمع للانزلاق الى
حرب اهليه تصريحات حاكم اقليم دارفور
عززها تقرير صادر عن صحيفه بالفرنسيه
التقرير حذرا ان حرب القاده بدات تاخذ
بعدا عرقيا في دارفور حيث تحول القتال الى
صراع بين قبائل مدعومه من الدعم السريع
واخرى من اصول افريقيا
الصحيفه استندت في تقريرها الى معطيات
عديده تشير الى دخول المعارك في دارفور
منعطفا عرقيا اهم هذه المعطيات اغتيال
والي اقليم غرب دارفور خميس عبد الله ابكر
والذي تعرض للاختطاف قبل ان يتم قتله
بطريقه وحشيه قوه الدعم السريع حاصرتها
الاتهامات بمقتل الوالي غير انها لفت هذا
الاتهام ودعت الى التحقيق
واليوم خرج قائدوا قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان محمد حمدان دقلوليؤكد الاستعداد
للتعاون مع اي لجنه للتحقيق في اغتيال
والي غرب دارفور وفي تسجيل صوتي قال دقلو
انه لديه دلائل ومعلومات عن قيام الجيش
بتسليح قبائل في الجنينه لاشعال الفتنه
بحسب تعبيره
قمنا خلال اليومين الماضيين بجراء اتصالات
مكثفه في مدينه جنين
على المعلومات الحقيقيه ومع ذلك شرعنا في
تسجيل لجنه التحقيق داخليه الى الجنينه
اتغسل حول الحادثه ومستعدي للتعاون اي
لجنه تحيه مستقله بهذا القضيه كما تعلمون
ان ما حدث في الجنان من قتال لم يكن
مستغربا بالنسبه لنا لقد حذرنا منه كثيرا
ولدينا كافه المعلومات حول عمليات التسليح
الذي تمت من قبل الاستخبارات الجيش ولجميع
الاطراف في الولايه من اش قال الفتنه
وكان مقتل عبد الله ابكر المنتمي الى
قبيله المساليد قد جاء بعد ساعات من
انتقاده لقوات الدعم السريع في حوار
تلفزيوني وكان الوالي ثاني شخصيه كبيره
يتم اغتيالها في الجنينه خلال ايام بعد
مقتل الشقيق الاكبر لزعيم قبيله المثاليه
طارق عبد الرحمن بحر الدين هذا وقتل ايضا
اكثر من الف شخص من قبيله واحده وفق
تقديرات الصحيفه الفرنسيه منذ اندلاع هذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
معنى من القاهره الان رئيس تحريري صحيفه
التيار عثمان مرغني استاذ عثمان اهلا بكم
معنا في اخبار الساعه هلا قربتنا اكثر من
حقيقه وجوهر الصراع الدائر حاليا الان في
اقليم دارفور وعلاقته مع هذه المواجهه
الدائره حاليا في السودان بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
طبعا الصراع في دارفور هو بدا
قبل ما حدث في الخرطوم يعني كان هناك حرب
استمرت فتره طويله منذ العام 2003 حتى
الان ما تزال اثارها جاسمه في دارفور لكن
هذه الحرب انتهت بتوقيع حركات دارفور
المسلحه على وثيقه السلام في جوبا واصبحت
ضمن السلطه الحاليه الواقع الذي حدث اخيرا
هو مرتبط شيئا ما بما حدث في الخرطوم صحيح
ان شعله الشراره الاولى والحريق بدات في
الخرطوم لكنها انتقلت بعد ذلك بتدرج الى
ولايات دارفور الفاشل في مدينه الفاشر
مدينه الجنينه مدينه النياله ثم الجنينه
اخيرا الوضع في الجنينه اخذت الطابع
مختلفا صحيح كانت هناك اشتباكات في الفاشر
تم احتوائها وكانت هناك ايضا في الجنايه
في نيالا وتم احتوائها لكن الذي حدث اخيرا
في الجنينه اختلفوا تماما يعني مش حيث
الشكل حيث الاهداف الاجنده الوقايه على
الارض كلها كانت معزوله تماما عما دار في
الخرطوم وعما دار في الفاشر والجنينه
ونياله في الجنينه الوضع اصبح عرقي يعني
هو قتال عرقي صرف وفيه فيه روح التطهير
العرقي وذلك اكدته البيانات الصادره من
الامم المتحده
العرقيه
الا تتشابك ايضا مع مساله الدعم السريع
والجيش
طبعا يعني هو في مدينه الجنينه الجيش وقف
بمعزل عن ما يحدث في الجنينه يعني هو لم
يحمل المواطنين هو اكتفى كما ذكر السيده
الوادي الذي اقتيل بعد ذلك ذكر ان الجيش
في الحاميه على بعد 7 كيلو متر وهو لم
يتدخل في ما يدور في الارض لكن الدعم
السريع كان هو العنصر الاساسي الموجود على
الارض هو قوه وعددا وهو الذي ارتكب كل ما
حدث في جنينه وذلك بالوقائع التي تمت وبكل
الادله التي في النهايه اقنعت المجتمع
الدولي الان انا لا اتحدث فقط كتحليل ان
نتحدث وفق البيانات التي صدرت من عده جهات
اخرها
الامم المتحده نفسها والاتحاد الاوروبي
وقبل ذلك الولايات المتحده التي اول من
ادعت ان كل هذه الاحداث يقف خلفها الدعم
السريع اذا لا مناص الان يعني ليس هناك من
شك في ان الدعم السريع هو المتهم الاول
الى ان يثبت غير ذلك المتهم الاول لانه
قادر على الوصول او مسلح جيدا وافراده
اكثر عدد ولانه كان شديد هل هل ترى فعلا
ان يعني كل مؤشرات الحرب الاهليه قد
توافرت خاصه في الجنينه ودرفور عموما
لا خلينا نكون محصورين يعني في الجنينه
نعم هناك حرب اهليه صرفه يعني لا يمكن
ابدا وصفها بغير انها تطهير عرقي حرب
اهليه لكن في بقيه مناطق دارفور في الفاشر
في نيالا في غيرها طبعا ربما استثني ايضا
الكتب وطويلا في الخرطوم ليست هناك حرب
اهليه الذي يجري في الخرطوم الان هي حرب
السياسيه بين قوتين تعتمدان على رايات
سياسيه واهداف سياسيه وجنده سياسيه لكن ما
حدث في الجنينه معزول تماما عن كل ما حدث
هناك وهي حرب اهليه من الطراز الاول اسوا
مما دار في رواندا شكرا جزيلا لكم على
تقريب الصوره لنا حول حقيقه ما يحصل في
الجنينه خصوصا عثمان مرغني رئيس تحرير
صحيفه التيار كنت معنا من القاهره
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا الان حيث دخلت كاميرا
العربيه الى مدينه افديفيكا المحاصره من
ثلاث جهات من قبل الروس الضفدكا هي احدى
جبهات القتال الثلاثي الرئيسيه في دنيتك
مارينكا
المدينه التي تبدو مهجوره تماما كما
تشاهدون فقد هجرها معظم سكانها خوفا من
عمليات العسكريه وخوفا طبعا على حياتهم من
القصر الروسي وتعيش المدينه او ما تبقى
منها على الاقل بعد الدمار الهائل الذي حل
بها في اوضاع انسانيه قاسيه ودون خدمات
في مدينه الحرب علمت المواطنين ان
يتشاركوا كل شيء هنا في هذا المكان وبشكل
مجاني يقدم المتطوعين بعض الخدمات
للمواطنين كما تشاهدون يوجد تلفاز يمكن
للناس ان ياتوا الى هنا لمشاهده التلفاز
هنا يوجد احد المتطوعين الذين يقوم
بقص شعر المواطنين الذين يرغبون في ذلك
يمكنك ان تشاهد هنا عدد من الغسالات
غساله الثياب يمكن ايضا للمواطنين الذين
بقوا في مدينه الى هنا لغسل ثيابهم طبعا
هنا يوجد كهرباء نسبه لانه يوجد مولد
للكهرباء كذلك يمكن ان يرتاح الناس هنا
قليلا هذه التدفئه ذاتيه تعمل بهذا النوع
من الخشب المضغوط
ويقومون بتسخين المياه لاستخدامها
للمواطنين الذين ي الى هنا طلبا للمساعده
هذا لمن بقي في المدينه من المواطنين
مدينه هجرها معظم سكانها ولكن بقي فيها
بعض المواطنين وهنا هذا المطبخ الذي
يقومون فيه بطبخ الطعام
للزوار او للمواطنين يقدمون وجبه الافطار
ووجبه الغداء في هنا في هذا المركز وكذلك
توجد هذه الصاله التي يرتاح فيها
المواطنين ويمكنهم ان
يبقوا هنا لمشاهده التلفاز
وشرب الشاي كذلك توجد هذه المنطقه التي
يقومون فيها باعداد القهوه والشاي
وبعض المشروبات الساخنه والبارده كذلك من
عصائر وما الى ذلك توجد صيدليه ايضا هنا
حيث يقدم الدواء
لمرضى الضغط والسكري وكذلك بعض اصحاب
الامراض المزمنه يوجد كذلك كما تشاهدون
هنا الخبز الذي يقدم ايضا مجانا للمواطنين
فيكا كذلك البقوليات المعكرونه وما الى
ذلك حتى طعام الحيوانات يقدمونه لمواطني
افديكا في هذا المركز كانت هذه جوله حصريه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من مدينه هي احدى
الجبهات الاربعه الرئيسيه في مارينكا
ولمان حصريا نقلنا لكم الاوضاع الانسانيه
فيكا لقنتي العربيه والحدث من حذيفه عادل
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه تطورات عسكريه
في الشمال السوريه على وقع انعقاد مؤتمر
استانا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه التوتر
يخيم على الشمال السوري في ظل التصعيد
التركي والتحركات الروسيه والامريكيه في
اخر التطورات دفع الجيش السوري بارتال
عسكريه نحو جبهات القتال شمالي وشرقي
محافظه حلب بحسب تسجيلات مصوره ورصدت
اللقطات المصوره تحرك اكثر من 100 ناقله
عتاد تحمل دبابات ومدافع متوسطه وبعيده
المدى وذخيره اضافه لعدد من حافلات نقل
الجنود
وتاتي هذه التطورات بينما تتواصل اعمال
الاجتماع الدولي العشرين حول سوريا بموجب
صيغه استانا وقال رئيس الوفد السوري ايمن
سوسان ان انسحاب تركيا من سوريا هو المدخل
الوحيد لاي علاقات عاديه بين البلدين
واضاف ايمن سوسان ان مكافحه الارهاب لا
تتم بانتقائيه مؤكدا ان ضمان امن الحدود
مسؤوليه سوريه تركيه مشتركه وتاتي تصريحات
سوزان هذه بالتزامن مع انطلاق اجتماعي
استانا بمشاركه النواب وزراء خارجيه سوريا
روسيا ايران وتركيا ويناقش الاجتماع مساله
تطبيع العلاقات بين دمشق وانقره والتي
ستكون مطروحه على طاولات النقاش
من دمشق ينضم الينا عمر رحمون المتحدث
باسم المصالحه السوريه استاذ عمر اهلا بك
معنا لماذا تدفع دمشق بتعزيزات كبيره الى
المحاور الشماليه
تحيه لك وللساده المشاهدين في الحقيقه هذه
الاخبار التي تتحدث عن حشودات عسكريه
وتتحدث تتنبا بعمليه عسكريه في الشمال
سواء كان في ادلب او في حلب هذه اشياء لم
اجدها الا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وليس لها اي اثر او اي تصليح رسمي لا على
الوسائل الرسميه ولا على موقع وزاره
الدفاع الان هناك اجتماع الدولي
واجتماعات سياسيه وهناك
اجتماعيه للدول الاربعه واجتماع السنه
هناك حوار سياسي هناك نقاش سياسي هناك
تفاوض وحوار بين الدول المعنيه بالموضوع
العسكري صحيح انه ليس هناك تصريح رسمي من
دمشق ولكن يعني هناك صور فيديوهات يعني
رصدت هذه التحركات صحيحه على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وهناك صحف كذلك رصدت
ذلك يعني وتناقلت الاخبار هذه وايضا وكاله
انباء
فيما يتعلق بهذه التحركات
هناك من ربط بمساله هذه التحركات خاصه في
ريف حلب
والمناطق الشماليه انه بالتزامن مع مسار
استانا وتجديد مسار استانا ربما الضغط على
تركيا ما رايك
سيدي الكريم بالنسبه لتحرك الجيش هذا
موضوع متعلق بوزاره الدفاع ولم يصدر عن
وزاره الدفاع اي شيء لا على الاعلام
الرسمي ولا على موقع وزاره الدفاع هذا شيء
واحد اساسي ينبغي ان نضعه بعين الاعتبار
لان تحركات الجيش تؤخذ من مصادر رسميه
وليس من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وعليه
اؤكد لك بان اي حديث عن عمل عسكري نحن
نامل لحظه قبل قبل اليوم قبل غد ان يكون
هناك تحرك عسكري وان يكون عمليه عسكريه
لتحرير المنطقه من انتظار البيان الرسمي
سيد عمر في انتظار البيان الرسمي فيما
يتعلق به اذا كان هناك فعلا حشود عسكريه
ام لا هناك تصريح رسمي للوفد السوري في
اجتماعات استانا والحديث على انه لا تطبيع
مع تركيا الا اذا سحبت كل قواتها الموجوده
على الاراضي السوريه برايك هل هذا وارد
يعني هل يمكن فعلا ان يتم الوصول الى هذه
النقطه في سبيل تطبيع العلاقات بين انقره
ودمشق
انا اقول لك بانه ليس هناك اي عمل عسكري
الان اتمنى ان يكون هناك العسكري ان كان
هناك عمل عسكري فهو عمل عسكري تركي على
مواقع قصد وليس اي عمل عسكري للجيش السوري
في المنطقه الشماليه هذا او من جانب
الجانب الثاني ما طرحته سوريا وشروط
السوريه هي شروط محددات تضعها على طاوله
الحوار
للحوار مع الطرف التركي طبعا هناك نقاش
يعني المساله السوريه التركيه مساله طويله
لن تحلى باجتماع ولا باجتماعين ولا بثلاثه
ولا بسنه ولا بسنتين المساله تحتاج الى
وقت طويل والى حوار طويل المساله معقده لم
تحل نعم هناك شروط سوريه لكن هذا كله يخضع
للحوار والنقاش بين المفاوض السوري
والتركي بضمانه الروسي والايراني ضمن
الاجتماعات التي تعقد الان
على مستوى معاوني وزاره الخارجيه وحتى
الوزراء الخارجيه هذا محدد اساسي هو
الانسحاب لكن
للانسحاب له ظروف نعم شكرا جزيلا لك عمر
رحمون المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه كنت
معنا من دمشق
[موسيقى]
لا تزالوا ضجه مركب اليونان الغارق لم
تهدا بعد مع استمرار التحقيق للكشف عن
المتسببين في هذا الحادث في اخر تطورات
القضيه تم توجيه اتهامات لتسعه رجال
مصريين بالعضويه في عصابه لتهريب البشر
ضالعه في هذه الكارثه ومثل الرجال التسعه
امام المحكمه في كلماتا جنوب اليونان
للاستجواب
هذا وارتفع عدد ضحايا غرق المركب ارتفع
الى 81 شخصا بعدما عثر خبر السواحل
اليونانيه على جثامين ثلاثه ضحايا ممن
كانوا على المركب ونجا لحد الان 104 اشخاص
فضلا عن 500 شخص اخرين في عداد المفقودين
[موسيقى]
رحله مشاهده حطام سفينه تايتنك تتحول
بدورها الى حادث جديد رحله مثيره باعماق
المحيط الاطلسي قبله سواحل امريكا
الشماليه انطلقت لمشاهده حطام تحولت لحادث
اختفاء جديد في ظروف غامضه لم تكتشف حتى
الان الرحله تمت عن طريق غواصه سياحيه
صغيره تسمى فما هي المعلومات المتوافره عن
هذه الغواصه شادينا هي غواصه تابعه لشركه
وزنها يناهز عشره اطنان ونصف الطن تسعه
اشخاص اذا كانوا على متنها
وثلاثه خمس اشخاص اذا كانوا على متنها
ثلاثه سياح اضافه الى قبطان وخبير محتوى
مهندس وهي مزوده بوسائل داعمه للحياه منها
اوكسجين لمده 96 ساعه وبامكانها الوصول
الى عمق 4000 متر وهو يتجاوز بقليل العمق
الذي يتواجد فيه حطام تايتنك وتدوم كل
غطسه كامله تقوم بها هذه الغواصه لمعاينه
حطام سفينه تايتنك ثمان ساعات تقريبا
نصفها للنزول والصعود
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نعود الى حادثه غرق مركب
المهاجرين عبر المتوسط الذي كان على متنه
750 مهاجرا في حد احد اسوا حوادث غرق
قوارب الهجره غير الشرعيه عبر المتوسط
ومحاكمه تسعه مصريين في اليونان بتهمه
الاشراف على عمليه تهريب هؤلاء المهاجرين
معنا حول هذه القضيه معنا من شبين الكوم
في محافظه القليوبيه في مصر معنى اشرف
غريب وهو شقيق سيد احمد المحتجز في
اليونان مرحبا بك معنا استاذ اشرف عبر
العربيه يا مرحبا بك يا فندم اهلا بك اخر
اخر المعلومات التي وصلتك من شقيقك عن
القضيه بدايه الاشرف اخر معلومات وصلتني
ان هم كانت المركب غرقت
قعد يومين اتنين ولا تلات ايام والاخر
بقيت رساله بيقول لي انا عايش
تمام ولكن اشرف شقيق شقيقك على ما اعتقد
اسمه سيد احمد صحيح
هو هو موقوف ضمن الذين يحاكمون ام لا هو
احد الناجين من المركب
تمام يا فندم نعم اقصد بسؤالي اشرف
الاخبار تقول الان ان هناك تسعه مصريين
يحاكمون من قبل اليونان بتهمه تهريب البشر
في هذا القارب
انا اخويا راجل نقاش وطلع مسافر زيه زي اي
حد كان مهاجر كان مهاجر اذا عبر هذا
القارب طيب احكي لنا قصه قصه شقيقه قصه
سيد يا استاذ اشرف
كيف راكب في هذا المركب ويعني قرر الهجره
عبر هذا المركب هو اسمه هناك احمد غراب
تمام يعني هو اسمه احمد غراب
طيب تمام اخويا سافر في رمضان
طيب
ويسافر في رمضان
خبر شرعيه طلع على ليبيا نعم تمام كان
متواصل مع ناس وطلع معاهم على ليبيا
وكده يعني
في ليبيا فجاه اتفاجئت ان هو قاعد في
ليبيا وهيسافر
وقال لي قال لي في فلوس هسيبها لك مستلفها
هنكمل عليها وهندفعها له عشان يسافر هجره
غير شرعيه وماشي زيه زي اي حد المبلغ
تقريبا الذي تقضاها المهربون اشرف المبلغ
140 الف
جنيه يعني تقريبا
بالدولار يعني
حوالي
اكثر من حوالي 4000 دولار
انا دفعتهم بالمصري
طيب وخلال وخلال تلك الفتره اشرف كان هناك
تواصل الى يوميا بشكل يومي كنت تتواصل مع
مع احمد
يقول لي هركب النهارده هركب بكره شويه كده
وهركب شويه كده ومخزنه طبعا كان في قلق في
ليبيا وفي وش وناس نزلت
زي الناس اللي نازله
قال لي لا ده صاحب اللي هيمشينا مش عايزنا
ننزل قال لك اللي هينزل مش هياخد فلوسه
وما فيش حد اسمه ينزل وكان ميعاتهم في شقق
هناك وما رضيش ينزلوهم من هناك
ينزلون اين تقصد عندما وصلوا
عايزين ينزلوا بقى بعد ما روحوا ليبيا
هناك وناس اتمسكت كانوا يريدون يعني
العوده الى مصر
نعم
[موسيقى]
لكن المهربين منعوهم يعني
من يعود الى مصر يعني لن ياخذ الاموال
التي دفعها للهجره
هتستنى هنركبك معانا
طيب
وبعد ذلك يعني اخر تواصل كما ذكرت في
بدايه هذه المقابله يعني لا تعلمون الان
مصير احمد
لا دلوقتي مش عارف اتواصل معاه ومش عارف
عنه اي حاجه خالص دلوقتي هو كان بعت لي
رساله قال لي ان هو عايش وكويس وانا مش
عارف اتواصل معاه ولا عارف ظروفه ايه كل
اللي بسمعه على الاخبار على النت ان يقول
لك هو متهم متهم ليه يا جماعه مش عارفين
متهم ان هو كان على المركب ازاي ما اناش
عارف بالضبط متهم ليه انا اخويا شغال نقاش
هنا باليوميه يا دوب بيجيب قوت عياله يقوم
بيوم ميتهم 150 جنيه
يعني انا اخويا يوميته 150 جنيه بيجيبه
يوم بيوم وعنده اطفال صغيره
طيب تمام تمام شكرا نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
على هذه المعلومات التي افدتنا بها اشرف
غريبا انت شقيق سيد احمد المحتجز في
اليونان اذا بعد غرق مركب هجره غير شرعيه
عبر المتوسط
فاصل نواصل بعده اخبار الساعه يبقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد حدد القضاء الفيدراليه
والامريكي وموعدا اوليا لمحاكمه الرئيس
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه السابق دونالد
ترامب في قضيه تسريب وثائق من البيت
الابيض الى منتجعه الخاص في مرالو في
فلوريدا وستعقد المحاكمه في الرابع عشر من
اغسطس المقبل
معنى من فلوريدا توم حرب مدير التحالف
الامريكيه الشرق الاوسط
يذهبون بعيدا في مساله الانقسام الحاد
الان في المجتمع الامريكي بسبب شعارات
ترامب ومحاكمته الان والانقسام الشديد بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين يذهب الى حد
التنبؤ بحرب اهليه امريكيه بسبب الانقسام
الشديد بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين هل
تعتقد انه فعلا ممكن ان تصل الامور الى
هذا الحد في امريكا
اولا مرحبا لك والمشاهدين الكرام اكيد ليس
هنالك اي حرب اهليه بسبب التشدد الكلام
بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين ولكن الشعب
الامريكي يرى بان هنالك نوعان من القضاء
القضاء ما يخص الجمهوريين والرئيس ترامب
وقضاء ما يهم الديمقراطيين ولكن الشعب
الامريكي في نهايه المطار سيختار الرئيس
القادم حسب الوضع الاقتصادي والمالي في
البلاد هل سيريد رئيسا الفائده باربع خمسه
بالمئه ام 12% هل يريد رئيسا ان يوقف
الحرب في اوكرانيا ام ربما سنذهب الى حرب
نوويه هل نريد رئيس ان يوقف
التقدم الصيني اتجاه تايوان اما نريد رئيس
ان ان تخضع تايوان الى الى الصين اين
موقفنا من العالم العربي ولكن اليوم الذي
نراه في الداخل الامريكي وخ في الجاليات
التي اتت الى الولايات المتحده ومنها
الجاليات العربيه هي بدات تغير
موضعها من الحزب الديمقراطي الى الحزب
الجمهوري لان الحزب الديمقراطي بدا ينكش
في المجتمع
العائلي في الولايات المتحده وهنالك تغيير
مهم من هؤلاء الجليات الات مؤخرا الى
الولايات المتحده نعم طيب ولكن المعركه
الدائره حاليا
فيما يتعلق بالترامب او المسار محاكمته
ايضا هل برايك سيؤثر او سيمنعه بالاحرى من
الترشح او خوض غمار الانتخابات الرئاسيه
او الفوز بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
عنه في الانتخابات المقبله
انا لا اتصور لان هذه كلها اتهامات
والاتهامات ستذهب الى المحاكم والمحاكم
ستاخذ ثمين وربما المحكمه ستاخذ مجراها
بعد انتخاب الرئيس وبعد ولايه مدته بعد
اربع خمس سنوات ونحن نعرف عندما يكون
الرئيس في في الرئاسه لا يمكن اي محاكمه
له في ذلك الفتره وانما عزله من الرئاسه
ولكن ليس محاكمته وانا لا اتصور سيكون اي
شيء طبعا الحزب الديمقراطي سيقوم بما عليه
ليحبط الجمهور جمهور الرئيس المرشح ترامب
ولكن جمهور ترامب هو جمهور قوي بدون شك
والحزب الجمهوري اليوم تقريبا يتوحد ربما
الانتخابات التمهيديه ستعطينا من سيكون
الفائز واذا كان الفائز ترامب
سيتوحد الجمهور
الجمهوريين وراء الرئيس شكرا
جزيلا لكم حرب انت مدير التحالف الامريكي
الشرق الاوسطى كنت معنا من فلوريدا نتابع
من ترشح السعوديه لاستضافه اكسبو 2020 حيث
استعرضت السعوديه خططها لاستضافه اكسبو
2030 امام المكتب الدولي للمعارض في باريس
واكد الرئيس التنفيذي المكلف للهيئه
الملكيه لمدينه الرياض ابراهيم السلطان
انه بحلول عام 2022 ستكون كل استعدادات
استضافه اكسبو 2020 جاهزه في الرياض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله انتهت شكرا لكم
على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات